Okay. Hey everyone, it's Michael Baltos
again and this is the Delta Scalper
analysis for July 25th, 2017. Uh before
I get started, brief disclaimer. This
presentation is for educational
andformational purposes only. Should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision.
Futures trading contain substantial risk
and is not for every investor. Investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment. Risk capital is
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle. Only risk apples should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk apples should consider
trading past performance. It's not
necessarily indicative of future
results. Now the tools I use in this
presentation are the delta scalper.
Actually I don't use the orderflows
trader but um I'm just going to show you
on bar charts. You can run on the
orderflows trader software but it also
runs on on bar charts for ease of uh
presentation. I'm going to show it on
the normal uh bar charts. Now, if you
already have the Delta Scalper and you
want the upgrade, it's free. Just go
send me an email. Don't send it to Mike
at Orderflows. That email has got
issues. Send it to upgrade
deltascalper.com and we'll send you out
uh the the the new files for you to
download. So, without further ado, let's
uh let's take a look
here. Okay, this is uh NQ. NASDAQ is a
eight range chart and really you know um
you know things like NASDAQ and things
like uh mini Dows is best best used with
uh during the cash hour best traded
during the cash hour u cash session um
you can see you know earlier there were
there were no no signals but you know
once cash session open boom you got this
nice move here cash session you know
this is 838 already you get this nice
move up here and here's a nice little
move here's a nice straight up move
here's a nice move up, get one here, and
then sell comes in, which fails. The
sell failed, then you're going into the
cash close here, which again, I think
you should personally I would stay away
from. Okay, here's gold. Uh, this a one
minute chart. Again, I'm not a big fan
necessarily of of of one minute charts
or, you know, I prefer range charts, but
again, you know, I want to show you how
it looks on on different types of
charts. Um, again, you know, it's and
it's all about, you know, taking your
losses. You'd have a loss here, loss
here, loss here, loss here. You'd have
four losers in a row. 1 2 3 four. And
you'd be sitting there banging your
head, oh trading sucks. It's rigged. Oh,
Mike, you sold me a, you know, you're a
scammer. You sold a bad indicator. And
then boom, here. So, you know, are you
willing to risk, you know, this move
from 1250 getting short at 1256 12 to
get out, you know, stop out 1257 when
you're getting short here at 125, you
know, 6 1/2 all the way down to
1254, you know, then you get, you know,
you're getting these nice little moves
here. Yeah, you have some losers. Okay.
Um, you know, every method of trading
has winners, it has loers. Again, you
know, I'm not a big fan of a one minute
chart, but, you know, I want to show
you, you know, yes, you can have some
losers, but, you know, you could have
some nice, you know, some nice winners.
Also, again, it depends on your style of
trading. You know, I know people that,
you know, boggles my mind. They trade a
one minute chart, but then they're
looking to hold it all day. You know,
you're trading a one minute chart, your
time frame is is very short, right? You
should be getting out over the next few
bars, especially if it's not working
out. You know, don't don't sit there and
hope and pray like this one, right? I
know people would get short here, think,
I'll take some heat. I'll take some
heat. You know, trades all the way up to
55 and then makes the move. You know,
then they said, "Oh, I'm a great
trader." Well, no, because you took a
little too much uh too much heat there,
you know, in this move up, you know,
what do you want? You want the short
moves straight up, you know, the short
moves straight up, the path of least
resistance, you know. So, I'll be
honest. You know, I don't trade gold and
you know, I don't necessarily trade
minute charts, but you know, again, I
want you to see, you know, so you can
judge for yourself. You know, depending
on your style of trading, you know, some
people will look at this chart and say,
"Hey, I could have made a lot of money."
Some people look at this chart and think
I'm an idiot for putting it up there.
But, you know, you got to see you got to
see all these trades. You know, here,
boom, I didn't even scroll to the end of
the day. But, you know, here you take a
small loss here, a small loss, then you
got a nice winner here. Another nice
winner here. You know, sure you have,
you know, small losses. You know,
everyone talks about, you know, taking,
you know, cutting your losses short,
right? But they don't really get into it
very much or, you know, have a method of
of cutting their losses short. You know,
that's why you see here these these
little zone areas, right, that are drawn
out. That that's to tell you, hey, you
know, get out at those get out at those
spots, you know, if you start going
against it. So, next up, I I'll show you
the Japanese yen, the five minute chart
this time. Okay. Not a lot of signals
today, but um you know what do you got
going back? Uh what's the overnight
session here? Nothing. Not until about 7
in the morning. A sell. This one doesn't
work out. Oh, Mike, you you're a
scammer. You took my money. Okay. Well,
you know, not every single trade is
going to be a winner. But look at this.
You know, if if you could be willing to
accept your small five tick loss here,
you know, getting short at 89 95 getting
stopped out at 90 90 even. Yeah, you're
getting short up here at
903 and what happens? It makes this nice
move all the way down here to
8976. So, yeah, you lost, you know, five
ticks here, but you made, you know, uh,
you know, close to 40 ticks here. And,
yeah, you got a loss there. Okay, fine.
Um, you know, 4:00, you're not going to
trade that just before
4:00. Okay, next up, soybeans, one
minute chart. Again, you I'm showing you
a lot of minute based charts because I I
do think there's there's a bit more
people that trade minute based charts
than than rangebased charts, but
whatever. I just want you to see, you
know, a bunch of different types of
charts. Uh soybeans again, market
reopens at 8:30 after the overnight
session. It's kind of volume in the
overnight session, but you know what
happens? Boom. Immediately delta scop
gives you a sell. But you know, again,
I'm not a big fan of taking, you know,
right on the open. Um you tend to get a
big surge market on open orders coming
in. Fair enough. Um, but again, you
know, if you did, you're rewarded. Here,
this buy failed. Here you get a nice
little buy. You know, it's a couple
cents. It's not the biggest move. Um,
then here you got a nice move. You know,
these two, you know, fail, but then
again, you know, be patient. You know,
take the trades when they present
themselves. Don't sit here and kick
yourself. I'm turning off my screen.
Trading sucks, you know, and then throw
the the ball, punch your screen or
anything like that. No, you know, being
a good trader is also about, you know,
understanding, accepting your losses
and, you know, looking for the next
trade. You know, are you a hunter or a
gatherer? You know, hunters go out there
and, you know, yeah, they shoot arrows
at the at the deer. You sometimes they
miss, right? They don't give up, right?
They still got to eat, right? So,
they're still out there hunting. And
then boom, next trade here, you know,
10:03 all the way up to uh, you know,
comes up here, you know, 10:06. That's
that's three cents, right? 3 cents in in
soybeans is three points in the S&Ps.
You know, soybeans had much better day
than S&PS. You know, that's why I always
talk about I always try to talk about
soybeans because soybeans is a great
contract. You know, 1 cent move in the
soybeans is a onepoint move in the S&Ps.
Yeah, when you get days of of 20 points
in the S&Ps, but you know, soybeans also
moves very nicely. you know, a lot of
fortunes have been made in the
soybeans and you know, so then here you
get a nice sell signal. Um, you know,
100 7 call it, you know, close to 10:08.
Actually, it's a 1 minute chart. You're
getting into the next bar. No reason to
get out here. But if you did, okay,
boom, you get another signal here. You
know, 10:04, a move all the way down to
998 almost straight very quick. So
that's another 6 cents. you know,
there's some great moves, you know, in
the soybeans. You know, honestly, if
you're not looking at soybeans, I I
think you're leaving money on the table,
but that's just me. You know, I I worked
at Cargill. Um, so I'm quite familiar
with the grains. And then, you know,
late in the day, you know, closes at,
you know, quarter after one, more or
less. You know, you got this buy here,
which didn't work. Again, I'm not sure
how you would have taken it. You know,
especially after, you know, a nice a
nice day like today. So, you know, by
now you should you should you see see
different types of charts, see different
contracts, and you know, you could make
make the decision yourself. Let's let's
take a look here. Okay, let's mix it up
a little bit.
Um, what do I
got? Okay, there is a 100 tick chart in
the mini DAO.
Okay, I'm just going to throw up a bunch
of different types of charts. This mini
Dow is 100 ticks.
Okay. Again, you know, I'm a big
believer in trading stock indices. Well,
E- Minis you can trade during the
European session because there's a lot
of ARB going on. I'm not necessarily a
big fan of trading things like mini DAO,
but you know, if you did, yeah, you get
some nice moves. Yeah, you get stopped
out on a couple of trades like this one.
This one, but then, you know, boom, and
that's a nice trade. This is a halfway
decent. This is okay. Maybe, you know,
that's a 830s right here. Um, start off
with a loser. Start off with a loser.
Start off with one, two, three small
losers. Why am I showing you this chart?
Cuz I, you know, I want you to see um
you know, again, you know, small losers,
small losers. And you know, be patient.
You know, the trades will come. You
know, here you get uh a nice trade here.
So you had 10 losers probably in a row.
Um you know, but then you know, be
patient. You know, it's all about
managing your risk. And these are not
big losers. These are not 20, 30, 40
point losers. you know, you're only
talking, you know, 58 to, you know, 58
or 10 ticks here on on each loss. I
mean, you shouldn't, you know, you don't
come into the trading day, take, you
know, your trading capital, divide it by
four, and think, you know, after the
fourth trade, you're either, you know,
up a lot or or down a lot, you know,
but, you know, this is 100 tick chart,
so it moves extremely fast. I mean, it
was kind of a slow day in the equities,
but, you know, still you got some decent
moves here, here, you know, little one.
I hate to call that a move there, but
you know, again, you know, for people
that trail their stops, you know, you
could get something out of these moves.
Honestly, I think a 100 tick chart is is
pretty fast. But again, I I'm showing it
because I I do know people that uh like
to live on the edge. You know,
personally me, I I I wouldn't trade a
100 tick chart, especially uh in a
contract where, you know, you could
literally put in, you know, 100 ticks in
in one trade. Um, so let me see what uh
you know what else we got. Uh, I wanted
to show you a a 987 tick chart. I'm just
looking for it here. Here we go. So,
this is a 987 tick chart in the uh
S&PS. Okay, so you start, you know,
early in the morning 5, you got a failed
trade here. Then 8:30, boom, you got a
nice sell. This one failed, but then it
came comes right back. You get a nice
trade
here. Another decent trade here. You're
getting short up here. kind of goes
sideways on you. Eventually, it does
sell off, but again, you know, from 11,
I wouldn't be in this trade all the way
up until 2:00. Um, then you go into the
close here. You again, you got this
surge in in volume
there. Okay, since we're on on a 987
tick chart, this 987 tick chart in the
crude. Um, again, going back to early
morning, you know, couple buys here.
There's a nice buy here. um is straight
up. You don't get any sells. It's just
more buying. So, you know, imagine
you're getting down in here along at uh
you know, 55
465, you know, all the way up to
4700 again. Um you know, it depends if
you could, you know, you should be
trailing your stop. Maybe you get out
here, you know, the first pullback, but
then again, you get another buy here and
then market makes a nice move up during
the day session. This sell a small sell
here. Yeah, this one nothing much. um
later in the day and another sell that
fails. Then you get a nice buy here.
Another um you know 15 20 ticks. Um the
sell I think would have stopped you out.
I I wouldn't have held it against me
like that. Um and then later in the day
obviously at at late in the day you got
that nice push up. You know again I
personally I I I stick to the old floor
hours. Um, you know, 237 is, you know,
after the old 210 close, but you know,
if you're one of those people that like
to trade it, you're rewarded. You know,
nice 50 60 C move very quick
there. Okay, so thanks for watching this
video. Again, you know, to learn more
about the Delta Scalper, go to the
website
deltascalper.com. Um, if you already are
a user, send me an email at upgrade
deltascalper.com and uh we'll we'll get
you hooked up with the the latest
version. It runs on Ninja Trader 7 and
we have a version for Ninja Trader 8.
Me, I'm I'm a I'm a Ninja Trader 7 fan.
I'm not yet sold on Ninja Trader 8.
Although, you know, people do use it.
You know, I I find
that most new traders, people new to
trading are are going directly to NT8
and then they're giving up on it. They
they don't like NT8. Honestly, I've I've
feedback that I got. Again, Ninja Trader
will hear that and then they'll ban me
or something. But honestly, you know,
that that's my feedback. Um, you know,
it's, you know, the the people that I
know that actually trade are still on
NT7. Um, but, you know, whatever. You
know, it's a personal preference. Me,
I'm still on NT. I keep saying I'm going
to make the switch, but uh, for now, I'm
still on NT7. So, anyway, um, that's the
details and, you know, enjoy. Bye-bye.